[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et le début d'une
nouvelle semaine d'information locale
sur tv 78 bienvenue dans ce set 8
journal tout de suite les titres de ce
lundi 10 septembre la visite de jean
michel blanquer redon les yvelines le
ministre de l'éducation nationale s'est
rendue à poissy vendredi et déplacement
sur le thème des dédoublements de classe
depuis la rentrée la mesure a été
étendue à l'ensemble des cp d'éducation
prioritaire et à certains ce1 la
campagne au sein des républicains des
yvelines se poursuit en octobre les
militants devront désigner le nouveau
président de fédération
parmi les candidats à la vice présidente
du conseil régional alexandra du blanche
une réunion était organisée jeudi en
présence de ses principaux soutiens
et puis la ryder cup à saint quentin en
yvelines c'est dans 17 jours dans cette
édition nous reviendrons sur une session
de recrutement organisée dans le cadre
de l'événement et nous recevrons le en
cours golf club dont certains de ses
membres seront en bénévole pendant la
compétition
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
était donc à poissy ce vendredi visite
dans une école de la ville dans le cadre
de la mesure sur les dédoublements de
classes et jean michel blanquer air est
venu rencontrer les enseignants et
parents d'élèves il a pu constater sur
place
le succès de ce dispositif déjà mis en
place depuis un an dans cet
établissement en des yvelines
isabelle karisko difficile pour le
ministre de l'éducation de trouver des
insatisfaits dans cette école
élémentaire de poissy le dispositif du
dédoublement de classes promesse de
campagne de manuel valls rond a été ici
mises en oeuvre dès la rentrée 2010 est
pour les cp et étendue cette année au
ce1 cette école de poissy est
emblématique que nous voulons pour
l'ensemble de
la france envers les professeurs sont
amenés à faire toute une série
d'innovations avoir des petits ateliers
à travailler de façon plus personnalisée
on voit des parents qui sont très
heureux de cette situation qu'ils sont
dans un lien plus étroit avec l'école
qui participent à cette logique de
réussite de leurs enfants dans le
département des yvelines 350 et une
classe de 71 écoles sont concernées
cette année des classes dont la moyenne
du nombre d'écoliers a chuté à moins de
douze élèves alors même que nous sommes
dans en ile-de-france dans des
territoires qui sont réputés défavorisés
et parfois en difficulté
en réalité vous avez ici je dirais des
graines d'optimisme
même constat pour le maire de poissy
cette mesure serait une réussite à long
terme
il ya une meilleure motivation de la
part de ces jeunes qui sont sans
complexe jeudi sans complexe parce que
comme je le disais à monsieur le
ministre
tout à l'heure nous sommes ici sur un
quartier prioritaire donc c'est un outil
d'intégration à de l'autre pareil les
seules critiques autour de ce dispositif
concerne le manque de locaux disponibles
dans certaines écoles mais dans les
yvelines
on a trouvé la solution dans ce cas de
figure les enseignants travailleront à
deux dans la même classe et quelques
jours après la rentrée scolaire le
recteur de l'académie de versailles a
fait le point devant la presse daniel
filâtre a évoqué plusieurs sujets
notamment celui du dédoublement des
classes pour le réseau d'éducation
prioritaire
écoutez le au micro de mélanie poké on
atteint 100% de dédoublement quasiment 1
c'est un point important c'est un enjeu
de justice sociale il s'agit de faire
réussir dans les zones d'éducation
prioritaires les élèves tous les élèves
nous avons mieux un apport de un peu
plus de 1900 professeurs stagiaires et
puis nous avons un but un peu plus de
600 créations de postes qui nous
permette à la fois de faire face au cp
des doublés de faire face à la
démographie d'améliorer notre taux
d'encadrement et puis d'augmenter le
nombre de professeurs remplaçants
c'était nécessaire et puis de proposer
une augmentation de la formation pour
nos professeurs politique avec une
élection en internat les républicains
des yvelines organise les 13 et 14
octobre prochains le scrutin pour
désigner le président de fédération est
la vice président
du conseil régional alexandra dublanchet
candidate ce jeudi dernier avec othman
nasri elle a organisé une réunion
publique à la salle ravel de vélizy une
invitée de poids présente la présidente
de la région ile de france valérie
pécresse reportage de nicolas landry
détermination et re mobilisation pour la
rentrée politique d'alexandra dublanche
la candidate à la présidence de la
fédération les républicains des yvelines
a organisé une réunion publique avec
comme soutient valérie pécresse
tout un symbole pour la présidente de la
région ile de france
je veux vit aujourd'hui comme une femme
qui passe le témoin à une autre femme
alexandra du blanche parce que mon
soutien c'est pas un soutien contre
quiconque
c'est une envie de renouvellement vous
savez se renouveler se rajeunir se
féminiser c'est absolument indispensable
pour les partis politiques
le renouvellement la ligne suivie par
alexandra dublanche des nouvelles
méthodes comme la consultation des
militants sur leurs attentes par rapport
à la fédération des yvelines et sur
différentes thématiques
nous on pense déjà que la droite ne
pourra que se reconstruire que par le
fond en travaillant sur le fond et sur
les idées en étant force de proposition
en montrant toutes nos différences avec
le pouvoir en place que ce soit sur la
hausse des impôts la hausse des dépenses
publiques
l'autorité de l'état la lutte contre le
terrorisme on reconstruit une ligne il
faut qu'on soit crédible et derrière il
ya un sujet de formation
des militants qu'il faut qu'on fasse on
n'a jamais été bon sur les argumentaires
il faut qu'on soit crédible et qu'on
construise une ligne politique qui soit
équilibrée donc on y prendra toute notre
part si les adhérents veulent bien nous
faire confiance
près de 200 sympathisants ont fait le
déplacement des élus des militants qui
ont la volonté de voir alexandre a dû
blanche à la tête de la fédération
il est d'abord une vraie idée de
rassemblement au delà cola au delà des
clivages qui apparaissent aujourd'hui
dans l'est républicain il soit vraiment
en rassembleur de divers divers chapelle
soit laurent wauquiez valérie pécresse
je soutiens parce que ça leur met de la
jeunesse ça remet énormément de choses
qu'il fallait améliorer et avec
alexandra du blanche
nous avons cette possibilité là pour
participer aux élections internes 13
octobre prochain les militants doivent
renouveler leur adhésion party les
républicains avant le jeudi 13 septembre
nj - 17 la ryder cup arrive à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la coupe du
monde de golf se déroulera du 25 au 30
septembre au golf national avec la
présence de stars de la discipline comme
tiger woods est forcément c'est une
compétition qui est attendu avec
impatience par les clubs locaux qui
enverront sur place quelques bénévoles
pour l'événement ce club là vient de se
créer tout récemment c'est le guyancourt
golf club et deux de ses membres sont
avec moi en plateau laurent de viol qui
est responsable de l'enseignement au
guyancourt gold club et daniel de ligne
et qui est trésorier de cette
association bonsoir messieurs merci de
votre présence à leur petit tour de
table avant de commencer dans quel état
d'esprit êtes-vous à un peu plus de deux
semaines du début de cette ryder cup
gagnée de ligne s écoute et on attend
avec impatience cet événement qui qui va
assembler déjà les meilleurs joueurs
d'europe et d'amérique et en plus haut
niveau spectateurs il va y avoir 60
mille personnes par jour c'est ce qui
est impressionnant pour une petite ville
comme lui en cours une tribune énorme
aussi qui est la plus grande jamais
construite pour l'histoire c'est très
dur
ryder cup laurent de viol vous êtes dans
le même état d'esprit il ya un
engouement à deux semaines de cette
ryder absolument la vue
les différents forums des sports par
rapport aux nouveaux inscrits a ainsi
que tous les événements qui vont se
préparer donc on est en plein en plein
travail
et en plus elle se déroule à guyancourt
le lieu de votre club ça va être la
capitale du golfe pendant quelques jours
guyancourt exceptionnel alors j'imagine
c'est aussi peut-être ça qui a motivé la
création de votre club c'est aussi de
profiter de cet élan va générer la la
ryder cup le golf est pas forcément un
sport on va dire très populaire en
france c'est aussi voilà profité de cet
événement pour faire connaître le boeuf
en fait à guyancourt il ya l'open de
france
et là il ya la ryder cup et en fait on
s'aperçoit qu'il y avait pas de club à
guyancourt
ce qui est un petit peu aberrant donc on
a décidé donc quelques golfeurs très
très acharné comme nous on a décidé de
faire de créer un lien avec les
activités ont démarré ce mois ci en
septembre c'est ça on démarrait juste
après la ryder cup d'accord et on est
quand même bien occupée au moment
d'arriver au club donc c'est la rentrée
scolaire se fera à partir du transept du
3 octobre
mais vous vous le dite complètement
occupé à et certains de vos bénévoles
certains de vos membres seront bénévoles
pendant cette ryder cup est ce que c'est
important d'envoyer ses bénévoles sur
place on sait que la ryder cup c'est le
troisième événement le plus médiatique
au monde vous disiez 60 à 70 milles
spectateurs qui vont venir sur place
d'importants points un club local dit
d'y participer de mettre son grain de
sel dans dans cette ryder cup
écoutez c'est toujours intéressant de
participer à un événement qui ne verra
jamais on ne verra pas d'autre dans
notre vie réglée au cours donc c'est
très impressionnant
effectivement c'est très intéressant de
participer à ce genre d'événement mais
quelles vont être les missions des
bénévoles sur place notre notre club il
ya personne au niveau de bénévoles mais
yade dans d'autres clubs dans la région
qui ont des bénévoles déjà au practice
il est responsable de practice qui sera
un bénévole de
club région alors vous le rende mieux
vous ne serez pas à proprement parler
bénévoles sur l'événement vous allez y
travailler c'est ça pendant pendant sept
semaines de ryder cup
absolument nous allons équiper la fan
zone qui aura lieu sur saint quentin en
yvelines donc nous allons équiper cette
fan zone en atelier de jeu pour faire
découvrir ce jeu et puis l'espace que
nous avons au sein de l'asm une orange
nous accueillerons des uns des invités
du monde entier et puis nous les
amènerons sur la ryder cup pour leur
faire visiter pour leur faire prendre
part au tournoi revenons au goncourt
golf club voulait dit les activités ont
démarré après cette ryder cup et vous
êtes installé vous serez installé sur le
sporting de guyancourt les installations
sportives du sporting de guyancourt et
cela en fait en collaboration avec
agility golf donc en fait tous les cours
se feront dans le sporting de briques à
côté de vous qui êtes professeur de
gaulle qui allaitent responsables de
l'enseignement c'est un enseignement qui
va s'adresser à tout le monde aussi bien
aux jeunes qu'aux adultes cette pratique
du golf
oui absolument ou alors nous ne sommes
pas un golfe mais par contre nous avons
de très belles installations sportives
aussi bien intérieurs qu'extérieurs donc
ils sont mis à disposition par la
structure bouygues et qui vont nous
permettre d'enseigner aussi bien sur des
enfants
nous lançons également un programme de
courts parents-enfants puisqu'on sait
que c'est assez délicat pour les parents
d'amener leurs enfants sur une heure
d'activité
là ils vont pouvoir faire l'activité la
prendre et se développer avec eux donc
des cours par enfant qui seront données
et nous sommes également un laboratoire
d'analysé donc nous avons toutes les
dernières technologies à domicile radars
notamment je crois oui nous avons donc
trachman nous avons des plaques de force
et nous allons
encore d'autres technologies qui servent
aux meilleurs joueurs et que nous
mettons à disposition pour le grand
public
golfeur qu'est ce qu'on apprend aux
jeunes quand ils débutent le golf quels
sont les premiers gestes à apprendre aux
jeunes la première chose c'est faire
attention à ce qui se passe autour d'eux
sur une activité qui peut rester
dangereuse non pas par la balle mais par
rapport au club donc on va leur
apprendre un périmètre de sécurité à
faire attention à ce qui se passe autour
ensuite après nous leur apprendrons le
respect de l'environnement sur le
terrain est ensuite très vite nous
allons les faire jouer sur des petits
parcours compact des parcours adaptés
pour créer une pédagogie de bain fait
par le jeu est ce qu'au contraire
lorsqu'on est adulte qu'on n'a jamais
fait de gaulle de sa vie on peut on peut
commencer aujourd'hui
absolument il n'y a pas de y'a pas d'âge
nous avons des demandes même des deux de
gens qui sont retraités même retraite
enfin troisième quatrième âge 70 75 ans
et qui ont eu le désir
il ya quelques années de jouer au golf
ils n'ont pas pu et puis l'art
évidemment oui viennent chez nous on a
un club de retraités absolument deux
dernières questions pratiques avant de
refermer cet entretien les jours
d'entraînements seront programmés sur
quel jour de la semaine
justement c'est le mercredi le jeudi et
le samedi et à quel tarif on peut
pratiquer dans votre club
alors c'est donc ces 120 euros pour un
adulte de la cotisation est de 130 euros
pour la partie enseigner mois et on peut
bien sûr vous joindre sur votre adresse
mail qui s'affiche actuellement en bas
de l'écran merci à vous d'avoir été avec
nous lors endemol et daniel de ligne et
on vous souhaite une belle saison et
aussi forcément une belle ryder cup qui
arrive dès le 25 septembre à saint
quentin en yvelines et à 17 jours du
début de cette ryder cup pôle emploi et
saint quentin en yvelines ont organisé
une matinée de recrutement pour la
société avec l'hymne even france cette
entreprise aura en charge le nettoyage
des structures du golf national pendant
l'événement un besoin en main d'oeuvre
est donc nécessaire regardez ils veulent
apporter leur contribution à la ryder
cup
une trentaine de personnes a participé à
la matinée de recrutement de
l'entreprise clean even france une
société spécialisée dans le secteur du
nettoyage notamment pour les grands
événements sportifs
les structures sont assez bas 9 a monté
spécialement pour l'événement notre
mission à nous bat sara de maintenir les
et les structures en bon état et enfin
pour l'accueil du public
donc on est rentré en contact avec
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et le pôle emploi afin de vad
d'avoir un vivier humain de staff qui
habite pas loin de l'événement cette
entreprise mobilisera près de 180
personnes par jour durant la semaine de
compétition
ce matin là elle est venue recruter 150
collaborateurs en contrats pendant la
semaine de la ryder cup une chance je
fais poche et suivant le recrutement et
vu que l'accès pour que 4 juin d'une
cale ça ça peut être bon mais ça peut
être se relancer sur un autre projet ce
vivier humain qu'on
on recrute aujourd'hui bas reste dans
notre base de données on est très très
susceptible d'être rappelé pour les
événements d'après parce que même
vis-à-vis de la région de guyancourt en
garde l'open de france cayenne événement
moindre comparé à la ryder cup mais
quand même qui est pas cassé
considérable et qu'on utilise 80
personnes au lieu des 180 sur une ryder
4 pour les candidats retenus après avoir
rempli les documents la création d'une
accréditation est obligatoire pour avoir
accès au golf national et contribuer à
leur manière à la réussite de la ryder
cup à saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
en attendant la ryder cup le week-end a
été riche en sport dans les yvelines
bonsoir michael et demi d'euros pense à
grégory le monsieur sport de cette
rédaction de tv 70,8 alors votre
émission le 7-8 sport reprend ce soir
juste après ce journal mais d'abord
nickel et ce sera un rendez vous
habituel chaque lundi dans le jt à vous
allez à nous faire part des principaux
résultats à zilina il y avait notamment
du rugby ce week-end dans lé département
oui grégory ont joué ce week-end le
premier match du championnat de fédérale
2 pour sa deuxième saison consécutive
dans cette division plaisir a raté son
entrée en lice les plaisirs wa pas
encore prêt physiquement et tactiquement
se sont lourdement inclinés à domicile
contre le marcquois rugby score final 51
à xiii on écoute les réactions au micro
de notre journaliste nicolas landry les
impressions c'est beaucoup d'amertume
parce que bon c'est vrai que c'est
jamais agréable de commencer la saison
en prenant 50 points à la maison
maintenant ça va nous mettre dans le
droit chemin nous met un peu de plomb
dans la tête vous ce faut se dire qu'il
ya du travail à faire et ça va être
comme ça tous les week-ends et comme
l'année dernière on lâchera rien au
mérite pas une telle défaite maintenant
quand on maîtrise aussi peu de choses un
moment donné la sanction est un peu
obligatoire et ouais notamment les 3 4
premiers essais comprends c'est que des
défauts de notre parc que l'adversaire
va utilise à fond voilà donc un problème
c'est logique après cette défaite
plaisir pointe à la dernière place du
championnat de fédérale 2 ils devront
absolument se rattraper le dimanche 16
septembre face à gennevillois il n'y
avait pas que du rugby ce week-end
michael en football bien sûr l'équipe de
france qui jouait hier un match de
national league ont joué également la
première journée du championnat de d1
district on peut rien vous cacher un
grégory un tour d'horizon des résultats
à guyancourt débute par un match nul
contre à gargenville score final un but
partout
même résultat pour plaisir sur le
terrain de sartrouville de son côté à
maurepas n'a fait qu'une bouchée de
montesson en s'imposant à 6,1 à
l'extérieur un résultat qui leur permet
de prendre la tête du championnat
enfin le chesnay arrache le nul 3
partout sur le terrain douilles et le fc
mantois et hardricourt se neutralisent
de vue partout la 2e journée du
championnat sera programmée le 23
septembre prochain
enfin on finit amical avec le
championnat de nationale 3 2 de football
avec un petit nouveau je crois voilà
charlie tange le nouveau gardien de
versailles versailles qui joue
versailles qui gagnent ils ont réalisé
une belle prestation sur le terrain en
s'imposant 2 buts à 1 dans un derby
vinoy contre les mureaux un résultat qui
permet au versailles et de grimper à la
6e place du classement avec un bilan de
deux victoires un nul et une défaite
prochain match le samedi à 22 septembre
contre le blanc mesnil sûrs et drake
merci michael pour ce tour d'horizon et
je le rappelle on vous retrouve juste
après ce journal dans votre émission le
7-8 sport où vous reviendrez sur
l'ensemble de l'actualité sportive du
département
si vous avez multiplié les barbecues cet
été vous les avez sûrement croisé les
guêpes sont de retour dans plusieurs
départements
les entreprise de désinfection et les
pompiers ont assuré faire face à une
très forte hausse cette saison
la guêpe un insecte à la mauvaise
réputation mais ô combien importante
pour notre écosystème on en parle avec
vous françois lasserre bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes auteur est également vice
président de l'ot pile au pied c'est
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement
vous êtes basée dans les yvelines
notamment à guyancourt ça sert à quoi
l'hôpital sont les missions alors
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement
à des missions scientifiques des études
fondées fait des études scientifiques
pour savoir pour mesurer la qualité des
environnements en insectes et puis elle
a une grande partie pédagogique et
notamment avec sa maison des insectes à
guyancourt
un pardon en fait elle était à
guyancourt maintenant elle à carrières
sous poissy il ya une grande maison des
insectes qui est ouverte pour les
journées du patrimoine et la visite sera
gratuite de la maison des insectes et
elle se trouve dans le parc du peuple de
l'herbe à carrières sous poissy qu'est
un parc absolument magnifique on dire un
mot de ces journées du patrimoine à la
fin de cet entretien alors un rôle
pédagogique vous l'avez dit notamment
auprès des dégâts peuvent vous êtes
aussi françois lasserre auteurs vous
avez publié tout récemment elle est
super pouvoirs des petites bêtes chez
delachaux signé cela on y apprend que
les guêpes
elles n'ont pas que les mauvais côtés
qu'on leur présente
elles ont aussi bien des utilités et des
compétences méconnu oui alors c'est pas
facile les guêpes de les défendre quand
on sait vrai qu'on nous on apprécie les
insectes ou les insectes mais on sait
surtout que quand quand vous dites les
guêpes
en fait vous avez le souvenir de d'une
guêpe ou deux qui vous a piqué il ya
peut-être un an deux ans trois ans cinq
ans et votre esprit aggravé le fait que
les guêpes pic est en fait depuis vous
avez croisé des milliers de globes
awards parfois des centaines de milliers
diète seulement votre cerveau d'un rien
d'enregistré ils auraient dû enregistrer
tous ces passages de guêpe en se disant
tiens finalement je me suis fait piquer
en 2015 une fois donc finalement les
gaps ne sont pas si piquante que ça oui
l'idée reçue déjà écarté c'est que c'est
pas leur but finalement quitté l'est
déjà on se fait très peu piqué ou que
par quelques individus dans notre vie et
on peut croiser des milliers des
centaines de milliers voire des millions
de gays toute l'année qui ne nous embête
pas parce qu'on a fait l noël n'ont pas
du tout envie de nous embêter le seul
moment où on peut on risque de se faire
piquer par une guêpe c'est quand on
s'approche d'un nier qu'il ya quelques
gardiennes est encore parfois faut
vraiment aller vraiment tout proche du
nid quand elles sont en dehors du nid et
qu'elle vienne à table elles sont pas du
tout là pour nous piquer sais c'est pas
du tout elles seront elles sont pas sur
le mode je vais défendre le nid et
georges de l'écriture elles cherchent de
la nourriture qui vend qui va servir
rires des larmes vous pouvez l'insulté
lui fait à lui envoyer des mauvaises
ondes crier dessus elle se moque
complètement de vous il suffit de rester
zen seulement elle est très curieuse
elle est très gonflé et elle vient elle
rentre dans notre bulle et parfois en
son sens de la nourriture
on sent la nourriture ou on en a mangé
et on n'attend pas les quelques secondes
qui suffirait pour qu'elle reparte parce
qu'elle n'a aucune intention mais c'est
vrai qu'elle a l'air de nous en vouloir
mais non ils nous envient faut rester
zen vous l'avez dit rester zen c'est
vraiment le meilleur moyen de voilà de
passer un bel été parce que parfois
quand il fait très chaud les nids
deviennent un peu gros et on a plus de
gueule que d'habitude un peu plus tôt
c'est pas qu'il ya plus de guêpe cette
année c'est qu'il ya plus d'individus
dans une colonie quand il fait beau et
du coup les jantes en panique est
vraiment peur alors que vous pouvez être
entouré de gap à table si vous êtes zen
il ne vous arrivera rien quel rôle utile
elle joue ces guêpes dans notre
écosystème
alors
moi même comme je joue pas de rôle
écologique je suis un peu embêté de
parler des rôles écologiques mais je
vois très bien à quoi vous faites
allusion
le rôle écologique d'une guêpe alors
c'est avant tout d'être un prédateur
dont un insecticide complètement gratuit
on les paye pas bockel elles vont
chasser des mouches des chenilles des
punaises qui vont servir à nourrir leurs
larves et elle en chasse des millions
dit qu'une guêpe statut 5003 au cours de
sa petite vie au cours d'un mois donc
c'est un insecticide gratuit elles
participent à la pollinisation des
fleurs puisque comme les abeilles ce
sont des pollinisatrices alors en plus
c'est une langue un peu courte donc
elles pollinisent les fleurs qui sont un
peu courtes que les abeilles ne
pollinisent pas elle joue un rôle dans
la chaîne alimentaire et de nourrissent
les oiseaux elles servent à nourrir les
oiseaux
mais surtout j'ai envie de dire tous ces
rôles c'est toujours un peu autour de
nous mais j'ai envie de dire que si on
veut un monde sans guerre
ça veut dire qu'on veut un monde sans
insectes sans oiseaux sans rien du tout
et si on veut un peu de nature autour de
nous on est obligé d'avoir quelques
inconvénients et si on se fait piquer
une ou deux fois par an et encore moi je
me fais jamais piqué par une guêpe et
pourtant je les embête on se fait
finalement pas souvent piqué mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est vraiment
pas cher payé à la fois pour avoir ses
rôles qu'elle puisse jouer ces rôles
écologiques et pour qu'on puisse vivre
dans un monde de diversifier parce que
un monde où on sera tout seul entre
humains j'en ai pas tellement envie j'ai
envie de voir des oiseaux des insectes
et les oiseaux les insectes c'est aussi
avec quelques contraintes dont certaines
guêpes parfois vous le dites finalement
si demain on a un monde sans lèpre ont
fait aussi une croix sur toutes les
autres espèces sur tout le reste on va
pas pouvoir exterminer les guêpes on
pourrait pas exterminer que les insectes
qui nous embêtent et garder les bons
c'est pas possible
si on veut de la diversité si on veut un
peu de nature autour de nous bien il ya
quelques inconvénients de temps en temps
mais vraiment si on est zen et qu'on
fait attention jambette toute l'année
les guêpes à en attraper pour les
montres et de prêts etc
je ne me fais jamais piqué parce que
peut-être que je sais comment est ce que
je sais voilà enfin je sais qu'on ne
risque rien je vais je vais à leur
rencontre et le seul moyen de se faire
piquer par une guêpe c'est de cette
panique et le message est passé la guêpe
ce n'est pas notre ennemi merci françois
lasserre d'avoir été avec la moa je
rappelle hauteur et vice-président de
l'opi et l'office pour les insectes et
leur environnement organise ce dimanche
une découverte de sa maison des insectes
à carrières sous poissy vous en parliez
tout à l'heure
et c'est dans le cadre des journées du
patrimoine
11h à 18h l'entrée sera gratuite pour
refermer ce journal direction la vallée
de chevreuse soixante trois mille
hectares de nature de culture et
d'histoire qui feront une fois encore le
plein pour les journées du patrimoine
afin de faciliter votre séjour sur place
une association dormir en vallée de
chevreuse sélectionne pour vous est des
hébergements les précisions de jules
colis que ce soit pour des vacances en
famille un week-end en amoureux ou du
tourisme d'affaires l'association dormir
en vallée de chevreuse propose
aujourd'hui 18 d'hébergement dans le
parc régional créé il ya plus de 15 ans
par trois hébergeurs de la ville de
magny les hameaux
cette association ne cherche pas
simplement à proposer un toit mais
également une certaine qualité d'accueil
sont des hébergements qui sont
sélectionnés pour leurs qualités
d'hébergement et aussi la qualité de
leur accueil
puisque dormir en vallée de chevreuse à
une charte à respecter
il ya par exemple l'accueil des hôtes
être présent respecter l'environnement
puisque on est quand même sur le parc
naturel l'éventail est très large il y
avait des gîtes des chambres d'hôtes des
meublés de tourisme
sachant que la chambre d'hôte comporte
automatiquement un petit déjeuner servi
ce n'est pas le cas forcément dû meubler
au du gic
l'un des objectifs de l'association est
de mettre en avant des hébergements
aussi agréable cas typique comme c'est
ici le cas dans la grange de la gueule
ar murray réaménagé en gîte par ses
propriétaires il ya une dizaine d'années
effectivement nous sommes sur la commune
d'ars murray qui
est assez représentatif puisque
effectivement nous sommes dans un
endroit du parc qui est quand même assez
magnifique en lisière de forêt de
rambouillet on a essayé effectivement de
rester sur le patrimoine local et
proposer des choses
voilà tout en restant en adéquation avec
l'environnement surtout les objectif
premier c'est de se faire connaître et
surtout proposer aux parisiens qui sont
très amateur de break au vert de devenir
souffler un petit peu par chez nous
dosez passe est périphérique et de venir
nous voir en vallée de chevreuse des
objectifs qui s'accomplissent déjà très
bien pour une association qui ne compte
pas se reposer sur ses acquis en
cherchant toujours plus d'hébergeur dans
le parc propriétaire d'un gîte en vallée
de chevreuse vous savez ce qu'il vous
reste à faire
le 7-8 journal touche à sa fin les
reportages et l'édition complète sont à
revoir sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile
je vous rappelle ce rendez vous dans
quelques instants c'est la reprise du
7-8 sport belle soirée et excellent
début de semaine à tous sur tv 78
[Musique]
oh